I was literally mounting the sofa at 2
years old my brother would be like
you're not meant to be doing that like
and I would literally just be like Moun
I know I know it's but I was I was
innocent I was 2 years old I should have
had a conversation my mom should have
took me down but she didn't she shamed
me for it and so did my sister and you
know now I've progressed to this and
this is I was just destined to do this
do you do you okay do you have shame now
not at all I so you have no shame no
yeah I love what I do and I think do you
think with if you had no shame when you
were younger you would still be doing
what you're doing
I I don't know no I I think I think I
was just destined to this like I've been
in the adult industry I started
stripping at 21 and okay it doesn't seem
like your parents really could have did
anything to not put you on this path